hi there steve kaufman here it's a
beautiful day the sun is shining right
at me here
uh in my little room and i have
something i want to really i want to
talk about i'm going to talk about it in
english and maybe in other languages as
well
i'll tell you right up front this uh
video is in english someone complained
that my previous video in french
uh it wasn't clearly indicated that was
in french and he had to listen through
quite a bit of it and fast forward to
figure out that it was all in french so
i will try to be a little more careful
in that regard
i posted on my blog the linguist on
language about a
concept called auding a-u-d-i-g-i-n-g
and oracy o-r-a-c-y
this isn't like odding as opposed to
reading so listening instead of reading
oracy instead of literacy oracy being
the ability to hear well and speak well
as opposed to literacy which is the
ability to read well and write well
and there's all kinds of evidence that
the ability to to hear and to understand
to when we're listening is extremely
important
and of course the ability to speak well
is important that these are along with
the literacy skills very important to
the success of a society and the success
of
individuals in that society and i have
commented often here that the key to to
successful literacy
is is
the opportunity to hear a lot of words
and we know that children from families
where the parents
speak to them on a variety of subjects
that those children do better at school
they read better
maybe not immediately because in the
very early ages everyone is being taught
their letters and
and so they're all kind of at the same
level but as soon as that
initial part of literacy learning is
behind them those kids who have heard a
lot of words
just learn just read a lot better
because obviously it's a lot easier to
read words that you already know
because you've heard them
and similarly kids who are familiar with
a lot of subjects that have a lot of
general knowledge from listening to
their parents or others
they'll have an easier time reading
because obviously if you're familiar
with
the subject matter that you're reading
about you're going to have an easier
time reading and there's all kinds of
tests that have been uh
done
that show that
uh if you have two groups of
readers or let's say
learners learning a foreign language
and you give one group
you know a word list a vocabulary list
to study beforehand and the other one
doesn't get that list and then they both
have to read the same text there's no
appreciable difference in other words
you can't suddenly start memorizing
stuff on the other hand what really
matters is how familiar people are with
the text that they're about to read so
whether it be in foreign language
learning or literacy
the more words you have and the more
familiar you are with different subjects
the better off you're going to do
and so where i'm coming from on all of
this is you know obviously reading is a
major subject at school people are
taught to read
i wonder whether we aren't missing the
boat in that we don't deliberately teach
people to listen and work on their
listening or auditing skills
and and what's really happened that can
make this much easier now than ever
before
of course is the appearance of these
little mp3 players
and i know that my language learning has
taken off since i was able to get a hold
of an mp3 player because i can listen
while doing other things
what's more i notice
that i have a
better time concentrating
when i'm active
whereas if i sit in a chair and try to
listen i tend to lose focus
but if i'm doing the dishes
even if i'm driving the car
if i'm running around a field or jogging
or whatever i'm doing it surprisingly i
focus better
on the content of what i'm listening to
so what i want to propose
because in schools
most kids don't like sitting in a
classroom and being
you know taught at
um we also know that there are problems
in all
modern societies with obesity and
inactive children
i think there should be us a program
every day in school
where children are given something
useful to listen to
uh relating to what they are studying
and that they are then asked to run
around the field for half an hour
listening to this now a lot of people
say well the kids won't listen and
they'll listen to music well first of
all you can control you can give them
an an mp3 player that only has
whatever it is you want them to listen
to on that mp3 player so there's no way
they're going to listen to music
second of all you say they won't do it
but they read and if you think about it
if we didn't have books and reading and
writing
and people had only ever listened and
then you say okay now we want you to sit
down and stick your nose at this piece
of paper and just read it
there would be a lot of resistance
so listening to something is not
necessarily a more difficult concept
than reading
and particularly if you add in the
opportunity to go and run
and i think we should train people to
get better at listening and increase
their vocabulary and give them a variety
of interesting things to listen to and i
think that
from my experience with link and with my
own language learning
that people will learn more if they
listen and read
than if they're in a classroom with the
teacher trying to explain a bunch of
stuff
let the kids hear about it on their own
let them hear it more than once let them
hear it
in different formats stories articles
dialogues
going over some of the same material but
let them just absorb it in a passive way
while active
i'm convinced that people would learn
more
if they if they learned in that way if
that opportunity were made available to
them plus they would develop a skill a
habit which i think can be very very
useful in later life and that's the the
habit of learning while doing other
things so we'd we'd achieve several
things here we'd we'd
make auditing or listening a specific
skill that we teach in school
we would do it in combination with
physical exercise so we're also getting
the kids more active and if it's winter
they run around the gym they don't have
find some run on a treadmill it doesn't
matter
reduce the number of class hours where
the kids are being unruly and the
teacher is mostly concerned with trying
to maintain discipline in the classroom
and so we do all of these things the
kids will learn more in my opinion now
granted i haven't tested any of these
theories but it's just something that's
really come at me in the last few days
and we develop a skill that can be very
useful
throughout one's life
and if in all of that
and
i don't hesitate to say if we combine
the listing with something like link
where we people can deliberately
increase their vocabulary then what we
would do what we would end up doing is
increasing the vocabulary
of
these kids and eventually adults we
would increase their
familiarity with a variety of subjects
we would improve their ability to listen
we would improve their auditing skills
we would improve their oracy skills we
would also improve their literacy skills
we would have more successful people
more productive economy i mean the
overwhelming majority of of people who
are in prison
are people with very poor
literacy skills and probably as well
poor oracy or auditing or listening
skills so there you have it uh i'm very
interested in get in getting some
reaction to this
and uh i'll probably uh do it up in a
few other languages to see if we can get
some interest from uh speakers of those
languages as well so let me know what
you think maybe i'm completely
you know out of my mind which i probably
am half the time anyway
thanks for listening bye for now